hi today I wanted to talk about
something that I think is very important
and it is about how to learn the hardest
languages in the world
have you ever asked yourself and told
yourself that you didn't want to learn
that language because you heard it was
too difficult you know maybe you want to
learn Hungarian and you heard it's
impossible to learn or Mandarin Chinese
or polish I happened to meet quite a few
times for example 10 years ago a little
bit more than 10 years ago I asked my
aunt what she thought about Mandarin
Chinese she's she also the language
lover and she told me it's impossible to
learn so challenging all these
characters and tones you know it's
impossible just you know don't even
start and actually kept me from learning
Mandarin Chinese for years and years and
the same thing happened for example for
Polish or for Hungarian now I think that
what I did wrong is to believe in what
people said and and they themselves
don't even that was based on their
perception of difficulty in my aunt that
I didn't even know Mandarin Chinese so I
think that in this regard we shouldn't
talk about difficulty because difficulty
is something that is subjective all
languages can be easy all languages can
be difficult depending on who talks for
example I saw on one of the comments in
YouTube that somebody said the Japanese
is so easy but for me it's like the most
the most challenging language I've ever
heard so far so everything is relative
and subjective I think it more objective
term is complexity because languages are
complex systems like an airplane is a
complex system in the sense that it's
made of smaller and simpler parts the
same goes for a car and the language is
exactly the same it's made of many sub
parts now all languages are related in a
way in the sense that they're all made
of sub parts like phonetics grammar etc
etc and the thing is that we shouldn't
talk about difficulty and we shouldn't
talk about complexity because once again
we manage complex systems every single
day the mere fact that I'm speaking is a
complex procedure per se the fact that
we're driving
Carr was swimming we're walking they're
all complex things that we do naturally
a language learning is no exception
so I would rather talk about language or
linguistic distance between languages in
the sense that languages can be closer
or it can be not so close or distant
depending on how much the sub parts of
the languages overlap let me give an
example Italian and Spanish are close
languages or are considered close
languages because many of their
respective sub parts overlap for example
Italian Spanish overlap in terms of
pronunciation in terms of grammar
because we form sentences in a very
similar way in a very similar order and
in culture but Italian and Japanese are
quite distant because even though you
know Italian and Japanese are easier or
close in terms of pronunciation because
they don't have that many sounds and
they share quite a few sounds the fact
is that in the end their overall their
distant because the cup because of the
culture because of the way they form
sentences so it's important to talk in
terms of distance and I'm going to base
my next what what I'm going to say next
and my tips so to say based on this
concept of distance so let me give an
example it's very important when you
start when you decide to learn a
language distant language so to say to
know where you're going in this regard
what you have to do is it's paramount is
to check your assumptions when people
say this is impossible to learn remember
this is their perception of difficulty
this is what they think something that
is difficult for them might not be
difficult for you so there's a bunch of
things in which we believe that are
actually not true but that we heard so
many times that we take for granted and
getting rid of that and listen to your
inner voice is the very first step
towards this journey then the second the
second very important step is to
actually figure out why you're learning
a language it is absolutely paramount
that you understand why you're doing
something and you don't have to base it
on hearsay something like a
cool to learn Spanish so let me give it
a try or I heard that it's cool to speak
this language and you want to speak it
because it's cool in general you know or
that a lot of people are learning it
it's fashionable these are all extrinsic
reasons they come from outside they're
weak and what is going to happen that in
the long either in the short or long
term probably more in the short term
you're going to give up because you're
not supported by valid reasons the
reasons have to come from inside and you
have to think about them so that you
know they drive there they're going to
be your driving force something that
comes from inside is the result of
feelings that you develop when you when
you have certain experiences so if you
can go to the country or get to know a
native speaker spend time with the
culture of the language read a book get
interested in it that is what is going
to you know to push you forward in the
long term it's very very important even
before you start this journey this is
absolutely paramount tip number three or
step number three is the fact that you
have to plan your time so planning your
time first comes from deciding having
very clear short as long as long-term
goals meaning that's suppose that for
example a native English speaker you
could be you I want to learn German then
let's say that you want to reach in two
years you want to speak the language
fluently but then you have to think when
once you have a long term goal you have
to think about a short term goal one is
your short term goal in for example six
months what do you want to do with the
language in six months let's suppose
that you want to reach basic fluency in
six months well that means that you have
a certain amount of time six months 180
days to reach basic fluency in the
language so let's do the math 180 days
and let's say that you needs you need
moral more or less 2200 hours to reach
fluency in say basic fluency in German
so it's more or less one hour a day so
this the fact that you have a short term
goal just defines how much time you can
spend daily once you know that you can
start planning say a month on Sunday for
example you can tell yourself you know
what
I want to dedicate time to this because
time it's not something you have or
don't have something time is something
that you dedicate you find the time to
do something and you start planning the
week before and he start saying okay I'm
going to dedicate this amount of time
every day this slot this time slot on
Monday this time slot on Tuesday and so
on this is another very important thing
because if you don't plan then you know
on a day you say okay I've done a number
of things and let's let me do some
German and then you're tired and your
energy is slow and you're not going to
do that and the fourth important thing
is the how how you're going there
meaning you have to have a method so
that method is your means of transport
it could be an airplane you know it can
become an airplane if you know exactly
what to do and in terms of method it is
very important that your method is
effective for you there is no one best
method in language learning
there's just the method or the methods
that work for you and to find it is a
matter of trial and error so if somebody
says try this if you heard that it's
cool you try give it a try if you don't
like it just take a step back and try
something else until you find the thing
that you like to do this is absolutely
important and the method has to be
enjoyable you have to do things that you
like your independent language learner
nobody forces you to do things that you
don't want to do so make sure that you
enjoy every single thing that you do and
the third thing is that the method has
to be flexible in that in the case of
distant languages focus on the things
that are the most challenging at first
because then things are going to get
easier much faster down the line easier
and faster down the line meaning for
example in Chinese and Mandarin Chinese
what I did is I focused I made sure that
I focused on tones from the very
beginning because that was the most
challenging part of the language and
then things got easier down the line
because of this decision and the fourth
and in the and this is very important
and it's important that the method be
flexible once again so you have to know
to recap you have to know you have to
get rid of assumptions you have to check
your assumptions and get rid of rumors
then you have to know why you want to
learn the language then you have to
how to learn the language and then you
just it's just a matter of covering the
distance you know it's not about
difficulty anymore it's not about time
it's not about distance it's about your
will to cover this path so thanks for
listening and if you want you can check
the article that it's quite lengthy the
article that I wrote on my blog and if
you subscribe to the newsletter you've
got to have a bunch of things that you
cannot see on on YouTube and they're all
for free and sent to you and after
burying a bunch of interesting things so
once again thanks for listening and the
last question for you is how far will
you go in terms of language distance by